what the Bible says about same gender
sexuality is quite clear what is far
less clear is why it says it we open a
table talk where each week I unpack
insights from Christian theology and
spirituality that help you become more
thoughtful calm and just a downright
great human being my name's Brett
Tilford pastor at the table at church in
Sachse Texas and today I want to offer
really part two of a series of videos
that I'm doing
we're basically I'm unpacking why I
believe that LGBT people in the
monogamous one-to-one committed marital
relationships are not in sin and should
be fully included in the life of the
church so my hope in this series of
videos is simply be a voice of calm and
clarity in the midst of what can be a
very loud and ugly conversation why is
it so difficult well mostly because it's
really become the battle line in our
political religious culture war and if I
want to know whether you know you are
real conservative or a real liberal
progressive then all I have to do is ask
you one question what do you think about
gay marriage and then you know I've got
you pinned
similarly if I'm wondering whether
you're a true Christian then I can ask
you know what do you think the Bible
says about same gender sexuality and in
a similar way boom I've got you pegged
so my point in this series of videos is
not to play the I got you game it's
simply to offer my own reasons for being
a gay affirming Christian so in my first
video I share a little bit more of my
story in a personal way this one is
gonna be a little more of a preface for
or an intro to how I approached the
Bible as a whole
in difficult passages like this and the
following videos I'll get into some
details of like actual texts like
Leviticus 18 and
20 Romans 1 will be another video etc so
I'll get to those kind of details for
now this will be more of an intro to the
text and difficult passages as a whole
okay so here's my big idea for today
scholar James Brown sent in his book
Bible gender and sexuality writes this
he says what the Bible says about same
gender sexual activity is quite clear
what is far less clear is why it says it
all right so what does it say for those
unfamiliar here's an Old Testament
example this is from Leviticus chapter
18 verse 22 it says you shall not lie
with men as with a woman it is an
abomination that's an Old Testament
example and the chapter 20 of Leviticus
says much the same thing here's a New
Testament example Paul writes in Romans
1:26 and 27 that because of this God
gave them over to their shameful lusts
even their women exchanged natural
sexual relations for unnatural ones in
the same way the men also abandoned
natural relations with women and were
inflamed with lust for one another and
then committed shameful acts with other
men and received in themselves the due
penalty for their error again what the
Bible says about same-gender sexual
activity is quite clear it what is far
less clear is is why it says it and
honestly after reading probably a half
dozen books from various perspectives on
this as well as many articles and
podcasts I can now spray confidently say
the whole debate centers on the why
now you might think why on earth do we
need to know why it says it you're just
trying to twist the scriptures if it's
something you want well that's what this
video is really about because here's why
I think it's important to ask why you
have to forgive my hoarse voice I think
the last few days so when when we begin
to discern the why it helps us gain
clarity around how those texts apply
today the phrase that brownson uses to
capture this idea is he says we have to
discern the moral logic of the text in
other words knowing why it says what it
says will then help us wisely interpret
it and apply it in our own context and
in fact I'd say until we understand a
why really on any verse in the Bible it
can be very difficult to know how to
apply that text I mean I think it's
something even a straightforward is like
the Ten Commandments
you know thou shalt not kill and if you
take that right and say okay well there
you there you go that's the teaching so
all war is a moral period well but you
know no no oh it's very clear though
shalt not kill therefore all wars and
want right in all of a sudden well no
it's well it's talking about you know
defending the defenseless and it and all
of a sudden right you can see how this
plays out okay so I actually think this
is a very very big deal because
historically I just used the war example
but there been other topics where the
church via much kicking and screaming
has been forced to do this and I
referenced these examples in my first
video and honestly we look back on these
topics today we say oh thank god like
you thank God that we've changed our
reading even though what the text says
is very clear for example in the New
Testament in the book of Ephesians
chapter 6 verse 5 notice this is New
Testament is not Old Testament the
Apostle Paul
he wrote these words slaves obey your
earthly masters with respect and fear in
sincerity of heart just as you would
show to Christ now what that text says
is super clear but what we as the
broader church had to ask was hmm
what was the cultural context of that of
that verse and in specifically of that
form of slavery if the Bible is
translated saying slavery and we have
slavery is that an apples-to-apples
comparison of slavery as practiced in
modern Western world including the
United States until just years ago and
ultimately the church decided no granted
again with much kicking and screaming uh
make no mistake about it they were
pastors who said look we can't question
this or else we're gonna lose the Bible
as our authority I mean and this is I'm
not making this up you can go back and
read examples of you know in the 1800's
and early nineteen hundreds of pastors
making these types of arguments like hey
we may not like it but we gotta follow
the Bible
you know honestly tip that I would
simply say well I don't think we lose
the Bible as an authority perhaps we're
simply losing it as the simplistic easy
to read and interpret document we would
like it to be rather than the
complicated text we actually
or here's another example this is the
one of women in leadership so the
Apostle Paul again in first Timothy
chapter 2 verses 12 to 14 he says I do
not permit a woman to teach or queue
exercise authority over a man okay so we
ask why rather she is to remain quiet
for and here's the logic for Adam was
formed first then Eve and Adam was not
deceived but the woman was deceived and
became a transgressor okay now notice he
doesn't say all right guys this is just
a local practice not to be applied
anywhere and everywhere I mean no this
is honestly a pretty powerful biblical
argument against women and leadership
period and notice again what the text
says is super clear the key question is
what is the moral logic of the text now
in this one this is a kind of good
example because Paul actually tries to
lay it out and by the way I say Paul
there have been some serious scholarly
questions around whether this passage
actually is Paul precisely because of
this logic and it doesn't seem to line
up with other things Paul says like in
Christ there is neither slave nor free
male nor female etc so anyway but that
aside notice well go Paul is routing his
argument in something that I mean let's
be really honest this strikes us as
pretty sexist um the women were formed a
second and besides it was Eve who sinned
first so what if church has done well
they have taken that text and they have
asked hmm okay is that persuasive is
that a compelling moral logic and I
think rightly more and more churches not
all churches by any means but more and
more are saying no no that's sexist yeah
and I realize for some people this is
just the end of the world that I would
suggest you know the Bible could be
sexist but it's okay it's not being hit
it's not being the world in other words
when it comes to how we read and
interpret the Bible um do we simply
acknowledge what the Bible says in these
instances and then announce that we you
know support the keeping of slaves and
the silencing of women no because
honestly that's not how texts work in
the lives of religious communities not
even holy texts they have to be wisely
interpreted and applied now does that
mean we can simply make you know the
texts mean whatever we want them to mean
again no we have to think it through we
have to offer arguments and
counter-arguments there's times of
discernment in the church but then over
time a certain consensus about the best
and wisest way to interpret that text
comes about and so in my next video like
I mentioned we'll get into some of the
details on these Old Testament passages
and eventually the New Testament and
just how other scholars have approached
them so that is all for today if you
enjoyed this video please like it share
with your friends comment and subscribe
grace in peace